[Musique]
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui dans science clic les
mathématiques de la relativité générale
partie iii géodésique dans les vidéos
précédentes nous avons défini les
notions de ligne d'univers de temps
propre au cours duquel se déplace un
objet et la notion de vitesse spatio
temporelle qui représente la direction
dans laquelle se déplace un objet dans
l'espace temps on souhaite désormais
pouvoir exprimer l'évolution de cette
vitesse au cours du temps propre de
sorte à pouvoir prédire la forme de la
trajectoire dans notre univers les
objets se déplacent naturellement en
ligne droite la ligne d'univers de
n'importe quel corps va avoir tendance à
tracer une ligne droite à travers les
différentes dimensions des espaces et de
temps cela provient du caractère
symétrique d'une telle trajectoire qui
n'a aucune raison de tourner dans un
sens plutôt qu'un autre
de cette façon on dispose d'un moyen
très simple pour prédire la trajectoire
d'un corps dès lors que l'on connaît sa
vitesse à un instant il suffit de
transporter cette flèche le long
d'elle-même pour former petit à petit le
mouvement de l'objet ce type de
trajectoire que l'on forme en
transportant la vitesse le long
d'elle-même
est ce qu'on appelle une géodésique dans
l'univers tous les objets se déplacent
naturellement de façon géodésique le
long d'une géodésique le vecteur vitesse
ne tourne pas on peut donc écrire que sa
dérive et par rapport au temps propre
est un vecteur nul
tout au long de la trajectoire le
vecteur vitesse de la pomme ne varie pas
cette équation revient à dire simplement
que le mouvement naturel des corps n'est
pas accélérer et donc que lorsqu'ils
sont au repos
naturellement les objets se déplacent
dans la ligne droite mais on a vu
précédemment que le vecteur vitesse peut
s'écrire comme la somme de ses
composantes x les vecteurs de base en
injectant cette expression est en
remarquant que la dérivée d'un produit
est égale à la somme de chaque terme du
produit x la dérive et de l'autre on
obtient une expression qui relie d'une
part les variations des composantes de
la vitesse et d'autre part les
variations des vecteurs de base tout au
long de la trajectoire
les vecteurs de base peuvent en effet
varier à différents emplacements de la
trajectoire
car la grille qu'on a choisi comme
système de coordonnées n'est pas
nécessairement régulière bien que le
vecteur vitesse reste le même en tant qu
objet géométrique ses composantes sur la
grille vont varier au fur et à mesure
que se déplace la pomme
[Musique]
lorsqu'on y réfléchit la variation d'un
vecteur de base le long de la
trajectoire peut être décomposé comme la
somme de sa variation le long de chacune
des deux coordonnées cela multipliée par
la vitesse de la pomme car plus la pomme
se déplace vite plus vite le vecteur de
base va varier pour chacune des deux
coordonnées on obtient alors une
nouvelle grandeur qui correspond à la
variation du vecteur de base le long de
cette coordonner cette variation
s'exprime comme un vecteur qui
correspond à la dérive et du vecteur de
base par rapport à l'accord donné en
question ce vecteur est très intéressant
car il ne dépend plus de la trajectoire
du temps propre mais directement de la
structure de la grille elle même ce
nouveau vecteur peut être exprimé en
fonction de ses composantes que l'on
notera par la lettre gamma majuscules
[Musique]
dans notre cas à deux dimensions ses
composantes existants huit versions
différentes de composantes pour quatre
vecteurs différents on appelle ces
nombres les symboles de christophe elle
ces symboles de christophe elles sont
des quantités essentiel à la relativité
générale car ils traduisent les
changements que subit la grille le long
des coordonnées ils contiennent par
conséquent des informations cruciales
sur notre système de coordonnées lui
même
en réécrivant l'équation précédente à
l'aide des symboles de christophe l on
obtient finalement l'équation des
géodésique cette équation très
importante nous permet de calculer pour
chaque composante de la vitesse son
rythme d'évolution à mesure que s'écoule
le temps propre l'équation des
géodésique permet ainsi de prédire le
futur et le passé du mouvement d'un
objet dès lors que l'on connaît sa
vitesse à un instant ainsi que la valeur
de chaque symbole de christophe elle
partout sur la grille
pour résumer toutes ces idées imaginons
non pas un espace temps mais simplement
la surface de la terre
on décide de quadriller la planète avec
un système de coordonnées latitude
longitude qui à première vue nous semble
parfaitement épouser la géométrie
imaginons maintenant qu'un avion se
déplace en ligne droite
lorsqu'un objet se déplace toujours tout
droit sans jamais tourné sa trajectoire
forment ce qu'on appelle une géodésique
ici sur la surface de la terre
la géodésie correspond à un grand cercle
tout autour de la circonférence sur
cette trajectoire géodésique l'avion se
déplace toujours tout droit sont
vecteurs vitesse ne change pas
d'orientation il ne subit donc aucune
accélération
pourtant lorsqu'on mesure ses
coordonnées on a l'impression que sa
trajectoire et courbes et ses
coordonnées n'augmente pas de façon
constante
en réalité sa trajectoire est
parfaitement droite
le problème ne vient pas de l'avion mais
de notre système de coordonnées
ce sont nos coordonnées qui sont courbés
leur axe ne représente pas réellement
des lignes droites sur la sphère par
rapport aux vrais ligne droite les
géodésique les cases de la grille ne
sont pas droites
elle tourne en partant d'un vecteur de
base et en le déplaçant sur la grille on
peut mesurer de combien ce vecteur
avariée à l'aide d'un nouveau vecteur ce
sont les composantes de ce vecteur qui
mesurent la variation du vecteur de base
que l'on appelle les symboles de
christophe elle les symboles de
christophe elle permet ainsi de mesurer
l'écartement de nos coordonnées par
rapport aux vrais ligne droite
[Musique]